- So, did anything interesting
happen this weekend?
In the wake of the now infamous second,
third Trump tape in which
the President seemed to try
to influence the Georgia
Secretary of State,
Brad Raffensberger, and said
specifically I just want to
find 11,780 votes.
People are wondering if
this is criminal conduct,
and if the President is
going to be prosecuted?
Well putting aside the
issue of the criminality
I'm going to try and do a video on that
as soon as possible.
Some people are pretty sure
that this is criminal conduct
including potentially one of the members
of the Georgia state election board
who has asked Brad Raffensberger to start
a criminal investigation.
Brad Raffensberger has said
that he is not going to
engage in an investigation
but he left open
the possibility that the
Fulton County district attorney
could very well start an investigation.
So stick around for that video,
it's going to be coming out very very soon
and check out my other Eagle Briefs
where I talk about the legal issues.
And I'll see you in court.